en otros vídeos presentamos la noción de
orbitales varios orbitales en los
diferentes sub niveles de los niveles
energéticos o capas de un átomo en este
vídeo vamos a practicar un poco más con
la configuración de electrónica en
particular vamos a revisar el principio
de aúpa output proviene del alemán
significa principio de construcción es
una forma muy útil de pensar en
configuraciones electrónicas más allá
del calcio vamos a practicar un poco
cuál es la configuración electrónica del
neón pausa este vídeo y piénsalo y como
pista pondré la tabla periódica muy bien
el león tiene un número atómico de 10 y
si estamos hablando de un átomo de neón
neutro tendrá 10 electrones los dos
primeros llenarán la primera capa a
nivel energético de modo que tenemos 1s
2 y luego los siguientes 2 van a llenar
la sub capa 12 s en la segunda capa así
que tendremos 2 ese 2 y luego tenemos 6
electrones más para llegar a 10 eso va a
llenar la sub capa
así que tenemos 26 cuál es el orden de
las sub capas o sus niveles que acabamos
de llenar bueno primero llenamos 1s
luego llenamos 12s luego llenamos 2p y
también puedes ver eso en la tabla
periódica de los elementos en la primera
fila estás llenando el primer nivel
energético en esta segunda fila o
segundo periodo estás llenando el
segundo nivel ahora qué pasa con el
argón cómo será su configuración
electrónica pausa el vídeo y piensa lo
bueno podemos usar la configuración
anotación de gas noble
podríamos decir muy bien tenemos la
configuración electrónica del neón pero
luego vamos a agregar electrones a
nuestro tercer nivel de modo que el neón
le agregaríamos dos electrones en el su
nivel 3 cc3 ese 2 y luego para llegar a
18 electrones tenemos 12 en este momento
vamos a tener 6 más que van a estar en
el sub nivel 3 p 3 p 6 así que en el
diagrama que tenemos aquí pasamos de 12
s a
para completar el neón y luego con el
argón vamos de 13 s a 3 p ahora cuál
sería la configuración electrónica del
calcio pausa el vídeo y piénsalo muy
bien el calcio tiene 20 protones así que
un calcio neutro tendría 20 electrones 2
electrones más que el argón entonces
podemos partir del argón donde van a
estar esos electrones aquí es donde el
principio de alfa es interesante sin
duda hay un sub nivel 3d pero en el caso
del calcio en lugar de que esos dos
electrones estén en el psuv nivel 13 se
encuentran en el psuv nivel 4 s de modo
que la configuración electrónica del
calcio es la misma que la del argón pero
en lugar de ser tres dedos aquí se va
directo a 4 s 2 por eso estoy dibujando
este diagrama así que a menudo verás en
una clase introductoria de química
primero llenas 1s sin sorpresas estás
llenando este primer nivel o cappa luego
llenas 12s
seguida llenas 2p y llenas tu segundo
nivel luego vas a 3s una vez más no hay
sorpresas luego vas a 3 p y esta es la
sorpresa y la razón por la que este
diagrama de out house es útil para fines
de configuración electrónica si estás
pensando en potasio calcio los
electrones adicionales ahora van a ir al
sub nivel 4 s así que ahora pensemos en
cuál es la configuración electrónica del
escandio pausa este vídeo y piensa lo
bueno el escandio tiene un protón más
que el calcio tiene 21 protones y si es
neutro también tendrá un electrón más
con relación a un átomo de calcio neutro
de modo que podría tener una
configuración electrónica similar
podemos tomar como base el argón tenemos
2 electrones en el subnivel o sub capa 4
s
así que escribiré 4 ese 2 el principio
de ausbanc este pequeño diagrama dice
que el otro electrón va a estar en la
sub capa 3d así que escribiré 3 d
y esta es realmente una configuración
electrónica precisa para el escandio
ahora si estuvieras formando un átomo de
escandio el principio de aute hace
pensar que primero llenas 4s y luego
comienzas a llenar tres de esos se
enseña en la mayoría de los libros de
química y en la mayoría de las clases
pero en realidad si comienzas con el
núcleo de escandio que tiene 18
electrones eso tendría una carga
positiva y cuando agregas este primer
electrón en realidad no va a 4s va a 3-d
de modo que este electrón en realidad se
agrega primero si realmente estás
pensando en construir pero no quiero
confundirte demasiado en este vídeo solo
estamos pensando en la configuración
electrónica y para eso el principio de
agua puede ser muy útil ahora para fines
de configuración electrónica estás en
3-d luego vas a 4p y luego vas a 5s y es
por eso que puedes ver este tipo de
diagrama en tus libros tradicionales de
química del primer año
así que la conclusión es que el
principio del fuego que aprenderás este
tipo de diagrama es útil para la
configuración electrónica y puede ser
útil usarlo mientras construyes estos
átomos electrón por electrón pero si
realmente quieres la verdad precisa una
vez que vas más allá del calcio se
vuelve un poco más complicado ahora otra
cosa que quiero que aprecies con base en
lo que acabamos de aprender son los
patrones en la tabla periódica de
elementos para qué elementos estamos
construyendo el subnivel es bueno puedes
ver que es para todos estos elementos
que tenemos aquí estas dos primeras
columnas estamos construyendo el
subnivel s pero parece que falta algo
aquí hay algo más que tenga el subnivel
s bueno desde este punto de vista
podríamos pensar que el helio podría
estar aquí porque el helio tiene ese su
nivel y por esa razón decimos que todos
estos elementos están en el bloque s
ahora qué elementos construyen los sub
niveles p bueno todos estos elementos
construyen el subnivel p lo completan
y debido a eso decimos que todos estos
elementos son del bloque p y estos
elementos del medio el escandio es uno
de ellos son elementos del bloque de
ahora alguna razón por la cual se llaman
bloque d es que si realmente imaginas el
principio de auga para formar átomos
puede ser tentador decir que si estamos
construyendo en la cuarta fila estamos
construyendo el subnivel 3d o en la
quinta fila estamos construyendo el sub
nivel 4 de ahora sabemos que eso en
realidad no es cierto pero desde el
punto de vista de la configuración
electrónica puede parecer de esa manera
y por eso se llama el bloque de aquí lo
vamos a dejar